Salut.
Aujourd'hui, je suis à Grenoble en tournée
j'en profite pour vous faire
une nouvelle vidéo.
Si vous avez suivi le vlog mensuel,
vous vous êtes rendus compte
qu'au mois de janvier j'étais
en train d'écrire un livre.
Petite exclu : j'ai la date.
Le livre sortira le 18 mai.
BAM !
J'ai balancé une info !
Et en ce moment,
je suis sur un autre projet,
oui, je suis derrière...
Et à chaque fois que
je vous parle de ce genre de chose
vous me demandez d'où provient
euh... la stimulation,
la créativité.
Et bien c'est la réponse de
ce Hack Life !
[Musique Générique]
La créativité,
tout le monde en a.
Vous en avez, j'en ai,
mon régisseur en a,
on est tous créatifs.
Seulement, il est intéressant
d'avoir les quelques clés pour pouvoir
accéder à ce processus là.
Et aujourd'hui, je vous donne
quelques conseils en vrac.
Quand vous  êtes sur un projet,
quelqu'il soit, changez de point de vue
un maximum de fois.
C'est à dire que vous changez
la caméra de place.
Dans mon spectacle, actuellement,
j'écris un passage sur Pi(π).
Et en fait, j'essaye de me
mettre à la place de Pi(π).
A la place de ce nombre là.
Et puis, après, j'essaye de me mettre
à la place de ceux qui ont découvert Pi(π).
Et puis je me mets à la place de ceux
qui, potentiellement, auraient créé Pi(π)...
on ne sait pas...
Et sur une feuille, j'ai noté aussi
tous les jeux de mots,
ou les images sur lesquels
m'envoyait Pi(π).
Pour vous dire, à un moment donné,
j'ai même noté la ligne 3
et la ligne 14 de Paris.
Parce que 3,14...
Vous faites un espèce de
brainstorming seul,
en changeant les points de vue
en permanence.
Et surtout :
notez ce qui vous vient !
Notez tout le temps.
Notez toujours !
Même si vous trouvez ça
débile et inutile : notez !
Un des meilleurs conseils que je
puisse vous donner aussi,
c'est de faire ce que vous aimeriez, vous,
consommer culturellement,
quand c'est des choses
culturelles.
Si, par exemple,
vous voulez faire de la musique,
faites la musique que
vous aimeriez entendre.
Si vous écrivez un roman,
écrivez le roman que
vous aimeriez lire
sur le thème que
vous aimeriez lire.
Ne cherchez pas
ce qui fonctionne,
cherchez ce que vous aimez,
vous !
Et en parlant de livre,
c'est très bien d'acheter des livres
que vous ne lisez pas.
Je sais qu'il y en a déjà
pas mal qui le font...
En fait, vous pouvez acheter
des livres que vous prévoyez de lire
à un moment donné.
Qui vous plaisent parce que là,
ils sont là, disponibles,
devant vous.
Cette phrase là, c'est une citation
d'un cinéaste qui s'appelle
John Waters,
alors, évidemment, il ne faut pas
le prendre au pied de la lettre,
mais l'idée finale c'est de pouvoir
aller piocher dans cette source d'inspiration
après, quand vous en avez besoin.
La zone de confort,
on en avait déjà parlé
ici, sur cette chaîne,
en 2016,
j'avais fait une vidéo
sur la zone de confort.
Il est important et essentiel
de sortir de sa zone de confort
pour pouvoir se stimuler.
Donc, faites des choses que
vous n'avez pas l'habitude de faire,
allez travailler dans des endroits
inhabituels pour vous,
allez voir des choses que
vous n'avez pas l'habitude de voir,
ouvrez vous à autre chose et
vous allez voir que c'est
très stimulant aussi en créativité.
Ne passez jamais à côté
d'une idée,
cherchez à creuser la moindre
idée qui vous vient.
Prenez le temps de ne rien faire
également.
De rester dans votre lit,
ou assis et de réfléchir.
Ce n'est pas "ne rien faire",
réfléchir.
Il faut se donner ce temps là.
Pour le spectacle que je suis
en train de faire actuellement,
la plupart des idées me sont venues
quand j'étais en vacances
au Mexique l'année dernière.
C'est à dire, quand j'étais dans
une situation de ne rien faire !
Dans les choses qui marchent
bien également,
c'est d'utiliser des post'it
ou des papiers
et de noter plein d'idées
et de les poser
et de les remixer entre elles
et de voir un petit peu ce qui se passe.
N'hésitez pas à lancer
des projets inachevés également
sur lesquels vous reviendrez
plus tard.
Ça, c'est quelque chose
qui m'arrive souvent ;
j'ai plein de carnets avec
plein de débuts d'idées,
et un jour, quand tu en as besoin,
tu peux retourner dedans.
Et puis, je pense que le conseil final,
le plus important que je peux donner,
en tout cas dans ma
méthodologie,
c'est de ne pas avoir peur
d'essayer de faire les choses.
Essayez !
Ce n'est pas grave...
Si ce n'est pas exactement ça,
ça se retouche.
Il n'y a pas un chef-d'oeuvre ou
un super jeu, ou un super film
ou un super jeu vidéo,
qui n'a été fait du premier coup.
Tout ça,
ça se travaille.
Donc, n'hésitez pas à
aboutir à des premiers jets.
Pareil pour le livre,
j'ai fait le premier jet en janvier,
et maintenant je suis
en train de le retoucher.
Mais le fait de sortir au moins
entièrement un premier jet,
c'est quelque chose de très,
aussi, valorisant
ça fait du bien.
Et après, ça vous donne
du matos pour travailler.
C'est une des questions récurrentes
qu'on me pose à la fin des spectacles,
en tournée. Donc je me suis dit
que ça valait le coups de vous en faire
une vidéo directement.
Hack Life ou Life Hack ?
Il y en a plein qui sont surpris que
j'appelle ces vidéos Hack Life
et qui me disent :
"Ce n'est pas ça qu'on dit."
En fait, c'est ça qu'on dit si
je décide que c'est ça que je dis...
Parce que, justement,
ce ne sont pas des Life Hack,
mais des Hack Life.
Ça a un léger autre sens...
Si vous voulez plus de conseils
sur la stimulation en créativité
et comment booster
un petit peu tout ça,
il y a un super site qui existe
qui s'appelle "Out-the-box"
Je vous mets le lien dans la description.
Ceci n'est pas un placement de produit.
Puisque si c'en était un,
j'aurais beaucoup d'argent et
je n'aurais pas fait de vidéo
aujourd'hui...
Non, mais c'est un site que j'aime bien.
out-the-box.fr
C'est cool. Vous trouverez d'autres
trucs comme ça, d'autres conseils...
Et, en fait, c'est stimulant de lire
des conseils sur la créativité.
Comme d'habitude, n'oubliez pas
de laisser un pouce en l'air
avant de quitter cette vidéo.
Vous pouvez également vous
abonner en cliquant ici...
Et puis rendez-vous, ben...
très bientôt
je pense :
début de semaine prochaine.
Ciao.
[Musique générique de fin]